today
僕の行っているライフセービングの目指すものは
事故を未然に防ぐことなんです
b 中ラックスはこのライフセービング競技の花形種目の一つで
うつ伏せの状態から素早くをギャラリー
助けを求めている人に駆けつける速さを競うものです
100年を超える歴史を持つこのビーチフラッグスで史上最強のチャンピオンと言われ
ているのがこのオーストラリア g の細胞ハリスという選手で無類の強さを誇ってい
ました
僕は2014年に彼に立ち
ライフセービング競技が国技であるオーストラリアの新聞でも紹介されました
僕がこんなにも強いシャンプーに勝てたのは
たくさんの人に助けてもらったからなんです
実は
12年前
18歳の僕は挫折を経験し人生のどん底にいました
幼い頃からすべてを賭けた野球で
一杯をしてはいけないという恐れから体が硬直してしまえ
ボールを投げることがまったくできなくなってしまったんです
僕は本当にどうしていいかわかりませんでした
そして
またこんな気持ちになるぐらいだったら
どうせ自分には何もできない
そう言い聞かせることで殻に閉じこもるようになっていったんです
でも本当は
たった一度きりの人生なんだから
自分が輝ける何かを
夢中になれるものを見つけたいな
そんな気持ちも
心から消えることはなかったんですよ
そんな僕を救ってくれたのが友達のこんな言葉でした
きっと大丈夫だよ失敗してもさ何度でもやり直せばいいし
人生たった1回なんだからたくさん失敗できればその分いろんな経験ができるんじゃ
ない
その言葉が僕の心に
一杯をしてもいいんだっていう安心を与えてくれたんです
だから僕はとにかく自分の興味のあるものに一歩を踏み出してみようと勇気を振り絞る
ことができたんだと思います
運動が好きだった僕は大学入学と同時にテニスを始めてみたんです
毎日の練習に加えデー車に乗ってる時とか
勉強してるときたか授業中とかずっとラケットを握って生活したんですね
でも結果を出すことができませんでした
その後も
サービ
総合格闘技
double dutch ととにかく自分の興味のあるものに全力で挑戦してみたん
です
でもどれもテニスと同じように自分にとってこれだっていうものじゃなかったんです
大学も卒業を迎えようとしていた頃
クラスの友達がアメリカで行われる
スポーツトレーナーを養成するための短期留学に誘ってくれたんです
そのアメリカの研修で僕は世界最先端のトレーニングに感銘を受けました
そして帰国後すぐにスポーツトレーナーなろうと思って猛勉強を始めたんです
そしてその主権を受講するために受けたのが
偶然に
日本ライフセービング協会が主催する心肺蘇生法の講習会だったんです
そこでこの言葉に出会いました
よかったら皆さんも想像してみてください
皆さんは
大切な人が目の前で苦しんでいる時
その人を守ることができますか
僕はこの時ハッとしましたそれまで自分がしたいことどうすればいいかと考えたんです
けど
誰かを守ろうだなんて本気で考えたことがあるとかと言われたら
なかったんです
僕はその時初めてライフセービングという考え方に感銘を受けました
そして資格を取得しライフセーバーになったんです
その後
b 中ラックスの存在を知りました
その時
これだって思ったんです
瞬発力には自信があったしなによりも速く走れば走るほど
守れる命が増えていくんだ
そう考えると今まで感じたことのないパワーが湧いてきたんです
でも社会人になった僕にはとにかく時間がありませんでした
だから練習場所は幼い頃によく遊んだ
緊張の公園の砂場だったんです
これ本当です
あの
こんなところでいったい何をしてるんですか
夢を追いかけています
3回の職務質問にも冷静に対応した僕は
ちゃんと説明しましたそれ警官の人もだんだん応援してくれるなんて3回のがいい
あのその朝帰ってます朝早く練習を行ったんですけど
3年間毎日スタート練習を行いました
そして反復回数が10万回を超えた頃
僕は日本チャンピオンになってました
その時涙がとめどなく溢れてきたんです
僕は実はこんな撹拌しますけど何体も諦めようと思ったそう
でもその時々で支えてくれる人がいてその人たちのことを思い出しました
僕は日本チャンピオンなりましたでも世界最強の王者歳もうハリスに他ならないことは
分かってたんです
僕は自分の心に聞いてみました
もしも今
この人生が終わったとしたら
僕は何に後悔するんだろう
僕の心はこう動いてました
オーストラリアに行って史上最強のチャンプに調整してみたいと
26歳の僕は日本での仕事を退職しオーストラリアに迎えました
車
練習初日行ったらいいんですけど世界チャンプがもあまりにも速くて僕も愕然としたん
ですよ
でも
諦めたくなかったんです
だから自分にとにかく出来ることに集中してそれを全力でやり続けたんです
すると
これぐらいあった世界チャンピオンの性
ちょっとずつほんの少しつなんですけど縮まっていったんです
そして5ヶ月間の練習と研究の結果
僕はあんな強いチャンプに勝つことができました
入ってるぞありがとうございます
しかし1週間後に行われた世界一を決める大会では銀メダルだったんです
僕のスタートは速かったんですけど走力で負けちゃったんです
b 中ラックスで世界一になるために走るのが速くなりたい僕は日本中の陸上チームに
連絡をして一緒に練習をさせてください
そうお願いしました
でも
陸上未経験の僕を受け入れてくるチームは一つもなかったです
人生何度も思い通りにいかない経験を積んできた僕は
行き詰まった時こそ
シンプルに考えるということを学んでいました
ビーチ落成世界一になるために誰に教えてもらうのが一番いいんだろう
そもそも世界で一番足が入ったって誰なんだけ
あ
ボルトだ
でも僕は彼の連絡先を知りませんでした
だから
助けを求めてみたんです
b 中学生同士の世界一になりたいそのためにボルドさんと練習がしたいです
だから彼の連絡先をしてる人がいたら教えてください
そう思い切って sns に投稿してみたんです
すると
ここに連絡してみてください
そうポルトさんにつながる連絡先を教えてくれた人がいたんです
僕はすぐにその連絡先に通しても世界一になりた理由を一生懸命に贈ったんですメール
で
するとジャマイカからすぐに返信がきました
分かったすぐに恋
一緒に練習をしようと
頭の中の常識では
一見不可能に思えても
動き出せばかなうことがある
本当に嘘みたいなんですけど僕ジャマイカでボールドさんとねそして所
どうぞ
そうなんですよ世界一ついてはれる練習は毎日世界のトップスプリンターたちが応答し
ながら走れたんです
そして遠いアジアの国から来た陸上未経験の僕のことをチームメートたちは
チャイナっておきましたん
北日本人なんですけど
でも僕は前を向き続けました
大悟はダントツで遅かったです行くであったことないんだよ
でも誰よりも本気で走り続けたんです
するとチームメートたちの僕を見る目が変わってきました
名前もチャイナから japan
そして件
帰る頃にはブラザーってもれた今車
ボールドさんアルコさんは僕を自宅に招待してくれてジャークチキンをふるまってくれ
ながらほんといろんな話をしてくれました
本当に優しい人でした
ジャマイカでの比較で僕の走力は飛躍的に伸びました
でもそれ以上に
自分の考え方や
一歩の踏み出し方ひとつで
人生は変えていけるということを学んだんです
しかし
日本に帰国した僕はとても悲しい経験をしました
朝の通勤ラッシュ時地下鉄のホームに女性が倒れていたんです
片手には携帯電話を握っていました
その電話の向こうではこの子のお母さんが大丈夫大丈夫なの
そう
何度もこの子の名前を泣きながら読んでたんです
通話時間はなんと47分間
47分間もの間ここを通りすぎだ
何で国もの人たちはこの子に声をかける余裕すらなかったんです
僕は慌てて救急車を呼びました
そして
今の世の中何かおかしいと思ったんです
だって日本は経済的にとても豊かで安全な国ですよね
でも自ら命を絶つ人の割合が世界で6番目に多いと言われています
そして
自分の人生に期待をして夢に挑戦しようとする子どもがとても少ないと言われています
経済的な豊かさと
心の豊かさは一致しないということに気づかされたんです
だから僕は
ライフセービングが海辺の活動ですが海辺だけじゃなくて社会全体のライフセービング
活動をしようと思いました
まずは学校や企業もあってかつての自分のように
一歩を踏み出せないで苦しんでる人を励ませたらという思いで講演活動を始めました
そして
自分の身を守ることのできる体力と
誰かを守ろうとする心を持った未来のライフセーバーを育成するため
ライフセービング運動プログラムを作り全国の小学校や幼稚園に提供しています
僕がこの人生で何度もくじけそうになったとき
いつも誰かが僕のライフセーバーになってくれました
きっと大丈夫だよ失敗してもいいからさ自分の好きなことをやってみようよ
苦しいか
苦しかったら逃げてもいいんだぞ
人生にあなたがしなければいけないことは一つもありません
だからあなたが本当にやりたいことを心に聴いてみてください
今辛いかもしれないけどさ人生体
辛いこと楽しいことちょうど半分ずつあるらしいぞ
僕はいつでもあなたの味方です
できる
きっとできる
そんな励ましの言葉があったから僕は一歩を踏み続けることができました
そして気づいたことがあるんです
日本一になったとか何かができなかったとかそういう結果じゃなくて
一生懸命に何かに向かうその過程で学んだことや
出会ってきた人たちの絆こそが僕の人生を豊かにしているんだということです
人が溺れているとき
本当に苦しんでいる時
目の前のあなたの助けが必要です
ライフセービング養った事故を未然に防ぐために
人を思いやる心
この心助けを求めている人がたくさんいる
今の世の中に広め
支え合え高めを未来を作っていきたいんです
でもそれは僕ひとりでできることでありませんだからもし共感してくださる方がいたら
仲間になっていただけないでしょうか
僕は
誰もが誰かのライフセーバーにという社会の実現を強く信じ
明日からも全力で走り続けていきますありがとうございました
[拍手]